everyone's probably tired by now
assisting the conference the entire day
and your blood glucose is probably low
again that for an early lunch but what
I'd like to do is really call to
attention with our topic today is we
presenting we've prepared a very nice
presentation i believe on race class and
gender and the idea of reducing HIV AIDS
related health disparities and minority
communities I am the senior vice
president for health services and the
chief medical officer for the health
department at housing works a
community-based aids organization and
one of them I'd say the largest
community-based aids organization in the
country so in terms of disparities which
is what this conference is about health
disparities we're looking at race gender
and class as dividing lines by which we
see we see clearly demarcated
disparities in HIV HIV has really become
what I would call a black disease here
in the United States and in the world or
i would say people of color or third
world disease and it's not HIV when I
say HIV it's the immediate stigma that
comes to mind as if it were different
from any other infectious disease and
the reality is that most infectious
disease affect disproportionately people
of color and poor people around the
world in the same way as HIV African
American and Latinos represent only one
quarter of this country's population and
yet there are more than half of new aids
cases an estimated 600,000 people black
people are living with HIV and eight in
America today it's a leading cause of
death for african-american men aged 35
to 44 and african-american and Latino
children represent over eighty percent
of pediatric AIDS cases in 2000 you can
only imagine what the number is eight
years late
seventy-eight percent of hiv-infected
women are minorities and most become
infected through heterosexual
transmission in terms of gender women
HIV the numbers are outstandingly high
the proportion of estimated AIDS cases
diagnosed among women has tripled eight
percent in 1985 to twenty-seven percent
in 2005 2005 women of color accounted
for eighty percent of all women
estimated to be living with AIDS black
women made up sixty-two percent of this
total hiv/aids is the leading cause of
death for african-american women aged 25
to 34 and eighty again eighty percent of
these newly diagnosed infection were
from high-risk heterosexual contact into
the data is the latest data that is
available from 2004 in states of leading
cause of death for black women again
aged 25 to 34 the third leading cause of
death for black women aged 35 to 40 for
the fourth from 45 to 54 and the fourth
leading cause of death for latina women
aged 35 to 44 twenty-six percent of the
diagnosed in 2005 hiv/aids cases were
from women and the majority again being
from black women sixty-six percent
latina women fourteen percent the screen
went black just touch the screen okay
again another graph showing us here in
terms of the proportion of or the
disproportionate people of women of
color who are HIV positive it's an also
an issue of not just gender but race and
class again you can see that it's not
only initiative aids but also of other
infections is these eighty percent of
all reported gonorrhea cases were in
racial and ethnic minorities and
eighty-two percent of all reported
tuberculosis cases so the stretch and
the difference is you see applies to
other infectious disease fifty-four
percent of the new HIV AIDS cases
diagnosed United States are black among
women blacks again account for
two-thirds of all new infections
in 2006 aids in America is a black
disease as stated by Phil Wilson
executive director of the black aids
Institute the only way for AIDS to be
over in America's forays to be over in
black America and the only way to stop
aids in black America for black people
to take ownership of the disease amount
of mass black mobilization and just
looking forward in terms of the black
HIV epidemic as I think it should be
called high infection rates among black
men who have sex with men in one Center
for one CDC study forty-six percent of
black game bisexual men in five cities
tested HIV positive it's an epidemic
growing without adequate resources
particularly in the south at the end of
two thousand four eight of the ten
blackest academics in the south where in
the south in each of which at least
sixty percent of residents living with
AIDS were african-american and there's
still a heightening treatment access
issue in states where Medicaid and run
White Care Act programs are struggling
to remain operative as their caseloads
grow and resources fail to keep pace
two-thirds of blacks getting treatment
for HIV AIDS pay for it with public
health insurance these are just some
statistics an average of here in New
York City which is the city that you may
see the Magic Johnson bulletins that
have come out recently there's five
people that die per day in New York City
because of hiv/aids as of 2008 more than
eighty percent of new aids diagnosis
again are it's a reflective of the
country are among blacks and Latinos who
make up half of new york city's
population people who are homeless New
York City are diagnosed with HIV five
times more than the rest of the
population lyric city contains to be the
epicenter of the age IV epinephrine
States and there's more than 100,000
people living with aids aids in New York
City today that's one in six people an
estimated one in four new yorkers living
with HIV do not know that they are
infected and last year more than a
thousand New Yorkers three everyday
found out they had HIV when they already
were diagnosed with dates so as we move
forward I just I want to use these
graphs to kind of preamp the rest of the
talks my colleagues are going to give
but the idea is that it's it it's not
just an issue issue
HIV it becomes an issue of life and
death when you look at life expectancy
among males in 1990 and comparing it to
2000 there's a huge gamut between white
and black so you can see that in 1990
the average life expectancy of a black
male was 60 it improved a 69 their white
counterparts one from 70 to 75 amongst
female it's the same thing from seventy
eight to eighty from 1990 in white women
and from 70 to 277 but you can see the
biggest disparity is still amongst black
males at least an order of six years
that white males live longer when you
extrapolate this to black babies in
terms of infant death for a thousand
live births you can see the tremendous
disparity in terms of ten black babies
dying compared to four white babies six
hispanic or latino and three asian so
there's a lot of work to be done and in
terms of just mortality again when you
look at neighborhoods in terms of new
HIV diagnosis if you look in the
neighborhood comparing two sites that
have high prevalence of HIV you look at
you compare for example in manhattan the
chelsea in clinton areas where they took
an average of 227 people with HIV and
compared it to Croatoan and tremont in
the Bronx with an average number of 174
very similar number the mortality rate
was astounded Lee higher in the Bronx 29
in Chelsea and 59 crotona agreement so
that tells you that the prevalence may
be the same but the mortality is much
much higher almost double from one
neighborhood to the other and with that
I will leave you with dr. Pavia she's a
medical director at West 13 street hi
Reese
basically what as Marcelo said I'm the
medical director of a clinic that we
have at housing works at 13 street so I
take care of mostly people living with
HIV I feel that HIV it's the disease
that's the best to highlight the health
disparities in the US and around the
world we have new treatment we have
fantastic medication and people can live
with HIV however HIV is as I've seen
this like quietly devastating our
communities of color and devastating the
African continent Marcelo said it before
me seventy-seven percent of the people
living with HIV in new york city of
person of colors i have that graph which
shows that people of color both latino
and black make up eleven percent time
higher chances of having HIV than white
people in New York specifically we can
almost do it by zip code when you look
at the poverty level in some areas that
we can recognize on the slides we look
at Brooklyn the Bronx in the darkest
areas are the poorest areas we can
almost put that slide put that map right
over the numbers of death due to hit HIV
about housing works we have four
location route around New York City we
treat people living with HIV we provide
primary care adult day treatment case
management transgender care syringe
exchange psychiatry and Henson enhance
mental health our population breakdown
yes we treat mostly male seventy-three
percent of male 23% female four percent
of a population of of transgender
experience fifty percent fifty-five
percent of black 27th Latino eight
percent caucasian and asian we speak
Spanish Creole in French in our patient
age range from 25 to 65 years old all of
our clients and patient lives below the
poverty level ninety percent of our
patient of an history of chemical
dependence
or currently using more than ninety
percent have a history of homelessness
or marginally housed seven seventy-five
percent even more than that our formally
diagnosed can access one mental illness
in ten percent or identifies a triplet
diagnosed or they have HIV severe mental
illness chemical dependency and
sometimes quadruple diagnosed hepatitis
C with comorbidities those are the
numbers but let's talk about our patient
that put let's talk about their stories
I'm going to first introduce to you a
nice and is asked 22 years old she is an
African American she was diagnosed with
HIV six years ago her mother and her
older sister both died of HIV she had
three children no not my HIV positive
but both of all of three of them are in
the foster care system she lives now in
a subsidized apartment and admits to
using marijuana every other day but
denies any other substance she has been
on and off of HIV see of arvs entirety
of viral since her diagnosis and when
questioned at first she reported a full
compliance is due to the side effect in
2004 she was diagnosed with a brain
aneurysm on a routine head CT but
because she was not only RV her CD for
was in the was ten actually I remember
the number she had a viral load of more
than 500,000 her neurosurgeon at the
time and I saw the note that he wrote he
said that she has a very poor life
expectancy poor prognosis doesn't need
follow-up then she came to us when we
first met her she refused HIV and she
told me I have something in my brain I'm
going to die anyway what's the point to
a social worker in her case manager upon
further questioning she admitted seeing
her mother and her sister died why
taking antiretroviral into them she said
I'm going to die anyway the medication
doesn't help finally we got her to start
a RV with a lot of work a lot of art
which a lot of visit we got her to start
medication on daily observed therapy she
would come to the clinic every day and
we will
look for her give her medication we did
that for a few months then we graduate
her to peel boxing she would come once a
week we put the medication in about in
pill boxer and she would go home with
that she became undetectable that was a
big big victory for her she felt believe
she felt she had the right to live so
she started to follow up on their
appointments she went to the
neurosurgeon full offer and ilysm and
started working towards get we gaining
the custody of her children as you
everybody here can know that's um that's
very difficult when you still live in
she was still living in a shelter at
that time since then now she's she's
living in an apartment but she met
someone earlier this year and decided to
have a baby she came to us as to have a
pregnancy test it was positive since she
had met this new partner she had also
stopped taking her medication she said I
had too many appointment I had to go to
the court had too many things to do I
stopped taking my medication when we did
our blood work we found that or HIV was
again advanced very low T cell 5 viral
load in the hundred thousand again but
this time with greater urgency we
started our outreach care coordination
medication adherence sending people to
her house having her come back
reluctantly but chief started medication
she's compliant so far till yesterday
she was compliant she's doing daily
observed therapy and she awaits the
result of her first lab since her
pregnancy she says I will do it for my
baby it takes a village that's a very
heavy coat in that climate but anyway
what we see in that in community of
color in America we were producing the
same the same pattern that we've seen in
Africa all families are wiped out about
the disease and I I don't see anybody
talking about it by the way our patients
face poverty abuse sexual physical
homelessness really limited resources
try to see a neurosurgeon with Medicaid
try to do that hey the challenge that
their face I realized I
oh I can't read the challenge we face as
providers and I can talk about that
because I am on the other side of the
table the challenge is that we it takes
enormous amount of resources to help and
heal our patient because of all the
barriers that they have when they come
to us psychological economical social
what we've tried to do is try to do
analytic approach try to coordinate
their care so when a nice did not want
to take a medication we sent the art
which worker the therapies the pastor
was involved the provider I was involved
trying to explain to her the nurse to
guide and help her suffer practical
problem also like housing SSI then to
educate and monitor her medication and
outreach her if he would not come really
the easiest and the smaller spot what
the pot I played finding medication that
she would not be have a side effect will
be resistant I was very the smallest
part I will go to your land down Yolanda
is 62 years old she is a female of
transgender experience she was mere born
as a male in Puerto Rico her mother was
a sex worker and you learned about
starting the sex work at seven years old
she has a second grade education she
doesn't know how to read all right she's
a monolingual Spanish speaker she
doesn't know what she when she wasn't in
fact infected but was diagnosed in 1999
in San Francisco she came to the clinic
in late 2006 and has not been on
medication has not seen a provider in
four years she was out however taking
female hormones that she bought in the
street she denied drug use but was
sharing needles to inject hormones she
was living in a shelter in protects
practicing sex work she agreed to study
RV and stop and to stop buying hormones
and injecting them if we would guarantee
that we would help a final mon help her
through the process of changing her name
and claim the femaleness claimer female
named Yolanda was started on hormone
therapy and after being evaluated by a
psychiatrist she was diagnosed with
bipolar disorder in Saudi on psycho
after living as a female for more than
50 years she completed she completed her
paperwork for an official name change
currently she's still involved in sex
worse and continues to live in a shelter
hasn't pan housing yet and that's a
priority because you know what is
extremely difficult for someone to live
in a shelter but it's extremely
difficult to live in a shelter when you
off transgender experience and we are
taking medication for HIV so it sat in
you it's a small victory we have found
our involvement with patient of trans
experience at housing US has open our
eyes to a population of great need where
the idea of harm reduction plays the
greatest role stigmatization that we see
through throughout our daily practice is
at the heart of the matter of how
patient are marginalized and don't seek
care d face discrimination but also they
are at great risk of a crying and
transmitting HIV the last person that i
will talk to you is Manuel Manuel we met
manual when he was 22 years old it was
diagnosed at 17 he had been followed
initially at an adolescent clinic and
wanted to move away from his family who
did not accepting sexuality Manuel
abused crack cocaine in the past but was
really trying to stay clean and when
when I met had been clean for a few
months he had been seriously here
seriously here but when it came he
really wanted to be compliant really
wanted to recover and you know start a
new on a new food he was doing well in
his early recovery but he was leaving
new shelter awaiting stable housing when
Manuel when Manuel started we first we
put him on the OT we try to not get
people on t OT but get them quickly on
seven days because that's easier for
them and manual started doing well you
had a low viral load meaning that he
wasn't taking the medication every day
what he was doing better Manuel didn't
met his boyfriend his boyfriend was a 48
years old man and moving in with the
boyfriend seemed a better option than
living in a shelter I mean we all would
agree nobody wants to be there the
relationship however was a violent one
with accusation of physical abuse
from both party actually and his partner
was actively using man well then we
lapsed and started using crack on a
daily basis you would go on binging and
you will not see him for weeks we would
send out which worker call him to no
avail again we started manual on daily
observed therapy and started effort of
outreach to maintain his adherents but a
few months later he was a bigger lies
and his kidney were failing manual was
started on dialysis after is discharged
from the hospital Oh after discharge
from the hospital his physical health
was so bad that manual was transferred
to a nursing home in the nursing home
his boyfriend would come to see him and
sometimes what drugs and manual could
not see him there so he walked out of
the nursing home when when he walked out
of the nursing home we said we sent for
him and he came to the clinic and he
decided he would try to you would leave
the boyfriend house instead he said to
us if I stay there I'll never get better
he used his crack and sells my
medication so we were meant to buy
outward outreach effort and try to help
him seriously to get housing in
coordination with that do dialysis
center we would send a van to pick him
up and get him to dialysis in November
however manoir was still was continuing
to miss dialysis in concern both his
doctor and his case manager went to his
place to take him to the hospital for
emergency dialysis his advanced age was
explained to him and everybody said you
know Manuel listen you really need to do
this because no this is your last chance
you really deteriorating in Manuel
stayed in the hospital for two days the
second day he walked out and jumped in
front of the a train and killed himself
we need hope Manuel was HIV positive and
it was advancing we knew it but HIV did
not kill him poverty and absolutely no
choice that he had except being with a
boyfriend that was using and beating him
back to his family who hated him for his
sexuality or stay in a shelter we need
change we have economic or constraints
Medicaid restriction state that is
indifferent and negligent to the service
of minority population
and every provider that serve a
population of facing such financial
constraint that those providers are
closing most programs similar to ours
are losing money and struggling to stay
afloat eight of nine of the ADHD program
for hiv/aids in New York City because we
see no I'm not talking about the south
now in new york city and i'm not talking
about Buffalo no offense we are in New
York City or closing and one closed in
January yes we can how long can we or
anyone else with the Mandate of Ealing
the porous the most disenfranchised
continue to provide the care that we
know our patient need in the world of
the 10 minute medical encounter who will
listen try again fail with our patient
and try last time and give them their
chance for note of humor I did I wanted
to be bipartisan so no change no hope
just war thank you I have a few pictures
of our clients and I'll introduce Adele
flat Oh who's the director of the
women's shelter good afternoon everybody
everyone still awake out there ok good
good because we have some really
important things to tell you and it's
it's really about hope and as a lot to
just told you it's about hope and making
change an orphan options to people even
in a very restricted environment
financial environment ok so I'm going to
go quickly through some of those
statistics because I think we covered
most of them but as you probably know
around the world women are now actually
not more than but nearly fifty percent
of all people people living with
hiv/aids and that total is about 33
million
okay in the United States high-risk
heterosexual contact is the source for
eighty percent of newly diagnosed
infections in 2005 in 2004 AIDS was the
leading cause of death for
african-american women aged 25 to 34 and
in New York City there's nearly a
hundred thousand people living with
hiv/aids and out of those nearly well
thirty percent more than thirty percent
of females out of that population of
female people living with hiv/aids you
can see the numbers black and Hispanic
women make up ninety percent of that
population I want to just touch quickly
on Caribbean immigrants in Brooklyn
that's a major concern for us because
the Caribbean in general has the highest
prevalence rate outside of sub-saharan
Africa it's not shown on the slide but
the prevalence rate right now is about
1% in the Caribbean and that's second
highest in the world and many of those
immigrants are coming to New York and
you know that slide showed you the
breakdown in Brooklyn I want to talk
about the Women's Health Center now this
is a very innovative model of care and
we have an adult day health care center
we provide primary care we have a dental
clinic on-site nutrition creative arts
gym exercise and every day we offer
breakfast and lunch to our clients and I
think you know this is important to to
emphasize that the reason that the
center was founded was in order to
address the special needs of women and
the fact that many of them did not feel
comfortable going to clinics which were
predominantly male this is one of our
clients who was happy to share her photo
with you and it's a painting hanging in
the lobby of our Center so at the adult
day health care program we have a
therapeutic comprehensive care model
which includes a chat
medical care we link with the existing
provider of the client if they have one
and there's a continuous coordination of
services of Social Work case management
we meet every day to review the clients
on cases and you know the day's
activities and there's a monthly peer
review of our charts and we keep a
central database of clients that the
staff can access at any point to see
what's going on with each client of ours
we also look at admissions and
discharges to determine if the setting
we have for the client is appropriate
enough because for some clients they may
not be able to meet the demand of the
attendance contract which is a three day
a week that they're committed to coming
three days a week three hours a day to
participate in health care groups and
then we also have mental health crisis
intervention and substance abuse
counseling this is a picture of our
living room basically our waiting room
and we have what i call community living
meetings once a week that are
facilitated by a therapist to build a
sense of community which responsibility
and networking and we also have consumer
advisory board meetings once a week to
discuss our services and the outreach
and commitment acts of recruitment we
have a creative arts therapists who
works very closely with the clients to
allow them different creative means of
expression that that's actually her
standing there in the red shirt and we
do very different things that a typical
clinic would not be doing such as trips
to movies dinner museums cultural
programs and special events it really
have done wonders for the one for
example we had um Valentine's Day shoot
with the women and you know took their
photographs and gave them back to them
they were really excited that they never
had the opportunity for a professional
photographer to take their picture we
also have supportive services we offer a
hot breakfast and lunch every day this
is our cafeteria and a sheriff who
prepares very culturally diverse meals
a welcoming environment we make sure
that every day at lunch time some of the
staff are sitting there together with
the clients that are very comfortable
and you know sort of informal setting we
have a life skills and empowerment
program our next speaker Gina is
actually the head of that program and we
offer we have a nice computer room with
eight or work workstations we do life
skills money management on as well as
computer training and help clients do
things I put their resumes together and
look for resources on the internet when
I quickly go through a couple of case
studies as my colleague vaati showed you
this is not just about numbers it's
about real people and the first case is
a Latino woman 43 years old who lives in
Brooklyn she was sexually molested by
her father at age 14 her mother was
murdered she was a prostitute for 20
years after leaving home and then her
therapist passed away recently and she
came into our Center with a lot of anger
and unresolved issues with her family as
you can imagine she came to us in
november two thousand seven and became
involved with our mental health services
and creative arts and began building a
social network with the other clients
especially the Latino woman who were
there and recently did a hair makeover
and showed a you know great progress in
building her own self-esteem the second
case is an african-american woman 30
years old lives in the Bronx she was
raped at age eight her father removed
her from the home then he died when she
was 15 years old and she described this
as the end of her life she was
incarcerated for beating her child
previously incarcerated for petty
larceny armed robbery she's a former
gang member drug dealer who also pimped
all the young women she came to us in
november two thousand seven referred by
the court system very angry using a lot
of profanity slamming doors and then one
day she broke down telling us that if no
one helps me take care of my child i
can't come here so again this is one of
the reasons that we have in our
Center a child carrying room you could
see a picture of it we encourage the
woman to bring their children to the
center and then you know we get
volunteers or sometimes staff to help
watch the children and in fact her baby
was recently nicknamed whc baby now
she's compliant with her medical visits
and legal obligations and even though
her mandated time with us is actually
over she's continued to come to the
Women's Health Center and she just
recently received a certificate of
compliance for her attendance and was
extremely happy about that in conclusion
um we just want to you know emphasize
that the gender considerations are very
very important and it's important to be
sensitive to the special needs of women
and providing a safe welcoming
environment as you can see from those to
some case studies that we presented many
of these women have suffered a lot of
abuse in their lives for men and so
having a center where they can come and
feel safe and comfortable and networking
with other women and in a positive
environment is absolutely crucial to
their well-being and that's our address
phone number and email if you want to
reach me thank you very much I want to
bring up Gina arias I to get out from
behind the podium kizim are you short as
you can see and what you want to see me
so I'm going to talk about class unequal
neighborhoods HIV and imprisonment and
I'd like to begin just by highlighting
some of the key findings of a report
done by the New York City Department of
Health called health disparities in New
York City I just want I'm going to
highlight a few of these things and then
get to the main lead here as you can see
in the first bullet point of your first
as well as african-american and Hispanic
New York was very disproportionate
burden of illness
image or death and if you look down to
the one that's bolded the rate of new
HIV diagnosis is about six times as high
among blacks as among women ok so in
2001 the life expectancy in new york
city's poorest neighborhoods was eight
years shorter than it's in his
wealthiest neighborhoods and if we were
able to take the all cause mortality
rate in wealthiest neighborhoods if they
existed in the poorest neighborhoods
more than 4,000 deaths could be
prevented each year so there are a lot
of factors that that create this of
course poor access to medical care and
healthy behaviors poor living conditions
and which are more common among certain
economic and racial ethnic groups okay
so we have a lot of slides here what I'm
going to do is flip through them quickly
because I'd really like to get to if you
look here death due to AIDS these darker
shades are the same neighborhoods that
von teese spoke about earlier central
Brooklyn and South Bronx yeah hospital
this is hospitalizations for drug use
same areas are darkened have the highest
hospitalizations with drug use same
thing for hospitalizations for diabetes
ok so in the port the poorest
neighborhoods in New York City or the
South Bronx East and Central Harlem and
North and Central Brooklyn where more
than one in three residents live in
poverty ok so if we were able to take
these maps and superimpose them they
these are the same communities that
we're talking about with with the high
rates of HIV AIDS drug use diabetes
asthma and some other things so we have
some questions up here is the city
mobilized are we putting an emergency
to action well no I'd say the answer to
that is and what I want to get to more
so is this question of criminal neglect
and Lahti also mentioned this in her
presentation there is has been a
negligence on the part of government and
this is something that's not new I'd
like to talk a little bit about some of
the policies that were instituted in the
late mid-to-late 1970s here in New York
City that was part of creating the
situations that we live in today and the
mess that we have in the mid oh okay in
the mid to late 70s we had a senator
year senator patrick moynihan he was it
the state senator here in New York and
some of the policies that were
instituted at that time and this was
these are things that he wrote about was
a policy of benign neglect and also
planned shrinkage of the cities so what
we saw in in these same neighborhoods
where hiv/aids and all these other
illnesses or have exploded we saw
closing of fire houses in these
communities we saw white flight we saw
white flight all all over New York City
um but you know we saw it particularly
in these neighborhoods also we saw an
epidemic of arson by landlords and and
or landlord abandonment so when you when
you go to the south when you look at
pictures of the South Bronx and central
Brooklyn and even now there's still
pockets of that though you look at all
this housing stuff there were people
that once lived there and how did it
become to deteriorate as such well this
was part of government policies that
that helped her to propel these
situations they were closing there was
mass closings of mental health
institutions at that time so in the
1980s we saw the growth of homelessness
and all these things are interrelated
here we're talking about
to be AIDS but I just just to highlight
that government policies new york city
government policies and state policies
help to create the situation and make it
worse some of some of these policies are
not we're not how do we say just in New
York City for example in the whole
United States we saw at this time
manufacturing jobs leaving the the the
inner cities so a lot of factories and
places where people who maybe didn't
have such high levels of education could
get a job with the living wage those
those opportunities were steadily
disappearing so so as a result you know
as I said decrease in housing stock
increase in homelessness and some of the
the the illnesses the diseases that
we're talking about thus became more
concentrated in certain neighborhoods
with the explosion of TV and also
hiv/aids and I'd like to recommend to
your book that talks all about this
called a plague on your houses for those
of you who are students and even those
who aren't students the the book is
written by Deborah and Roderick Wallace
and it really outlines how this process
took place so now we're in 2007 and we
actually have we have a continued
displacement in our neighborhoods in
low-income neighborhoods due to money's
coming back in or what listen white
flight or what people with higher
economic socioeconomics that is coming
back into the cities and the increase in
gentrification in our neighborhoods
people are becoming
or more at this place so and you know my
I think my um my my section was supposed
to be New York City and the globe just
just to emphasize this is something that
is a worldwide phenomenon my family is
from the Dominican Republic and their
places in the Dominican Republic where
landlords they don't want Dominican
vessels they want US dollars and you
look in the paper and it will say just
like that payment and US dollars so this
this some phenomenon gentrification is
not just happening here in New York City
but around around the world so okay here
george bush america is the land of the
second chance when the gates of the
prison open the path ahead should lead
to a better life and yet we know that
doesn't happen what I'd like to focus on
now is basically an equal punishment
this one I don't have and I can't see it
here touch the screen I got four lines
okay forget it I see nothing HIV drugs
and mental illness please help me okay
um I'll wait for the paper in the US in
2004 one-point-eight percent of prison
inmates were HIV positive more than four
times the estimated rate of the general
population so it's not working okay all
right all right come on over there okay
um could you help me fuck you suck
screen scroll through as I'm getting so
Jar related or something you're good yah
yah horses are a major reason for the
party
she goes in prison and if if you would
party just take over take a look at this
right here jurisdictions with the most
prisoners living with HIV is in New York
we have 400 4500 it makes living
detalles that's a prevalence rate of 7.0
so that's extremely high people okay no
go back with so us incarceration rates
by race again as you've been talking
about Vidya disparities this is
definitely disproportionate given the
numbers of black Latino slacks and a
penis in the population okay so in the
US we have 2.2 million people who are
behind bars I don't know if that number
shocks you but I hope it does unless you
really know about it we have the unique
distinction of being the largest
incarcerate opinion beings in the world
or none and thread prison is big
business extremely big business so the
prison industrial complex it is a
self-perpetuating industry based on
subjugating increasing numbers of people
in our communities okay by racial and
economic escapes loading we look down
about a bullet hard on crime political
posturing is almost considered
indispensable
apartment in America so back in the 80s
again we had the war on drugs which
continues to this day but the war on
drugs essentially was and still is alarm
poor people can gather Rockefeller drug
laws that create this situation of
disproportionate incarceration in our
communities and statistically if we look
at the stats join us if you re drugs or
use that pretty much the same way in
white communities in black communities
and in our dental communities and I
can't speak on other communities but
that I know and so you know when we talk
about physician why is it that then
again Latinos and blacks are
disproportionately being being targeted
and some of these policies do go down
right to the neighborhood level of
course policing and the different ways
that policing is done in our communities
okay so next one yeah I went 124 yes
change okay collecting sorry in any case
I leaving to move around on some black
criminality and deviants are racialized
so surveillance those focused on
communities of colors and I said even
though drug use and as as you can
imagine drug selling is probably the
same in each of those groups yet we have
a disproportionate emphasis on
communities of color targeted for
policing
also incarceration ok so the
prison-industrial Congress buzz Clinton
has created a vicious cycle punishment
in which which only further encouraged
to those whose impoverishment is
supposedly solved by imprisonment and
basically think about it this way in a
life cycle wrong way if you wanted to a
poor family let's say and by side for
example you attend substandard schools
because that's what is this and a lot of
our neighborhoods subsample employment
unemployment rate is very high they
aren't this is are a lot of
opportunities for work exactly not to
work and get a living wage ok so you
might dabble in in drug trade in petty
drug trade or other things possibly on
the point of let's say for example there
you're already there you are getting
ready to be targeted by police and you
know it you have you have a different
set of I guess opportunities even in
doing you know illegal things in certain
neighborhoods and whereas entire
socio-economic neighborhoods you will
need not have to stand on the corner
right and not be targeted so you get
locked up you come out the opportunities
the last the lack of opportunity still
exists and so you may go back and forth
back and forth into prison and out and
as if you would excuse me as if your
neighborhood didn't have a high enough
concentration of some
dition including HIV a when when you get
into prison you're really in an
extremely substandard environment where
HIV as we look so on that chart in that
table is is very high amongst folks who
are incarcerated and and you're
surrounded by folks were similar same
life experiences that you do and in the
prison's at least in New York State and
I don't know how in other states works
but the Department of Corrections health
departments are not overseen by the New
York State Department of Health it's
they don't have to you know do anything
that the nearest State Department on
says and hence in different prisons you
have different policies your folks not
able to access health care medication
anything's like you and Leo in prisons
of the same things are happening to
happen on the outside people having sex
people are doing drugs they are no
condoms in the prisons in regular safety
they are out there you can't access
condoms but you know think about it
you're if there's a stigma attached to
trying to get a condom and your email
compared to present each other in a gel
situation who you having sex with other
men so you know that there's a stigma
they aren't even accessing it but in
here are savers is there there's no
comment i'll be there are no
and we know that people are doing drugs
in the ensuing so you have you know you
have a whole set of conditions that make
things even worse ok so don't yes oh I
finally you get out reentry try to get a
job you know it's not easy people don't
want to hear about your prisoner people
don't want to hire people okay that's
one oh that's the last one okay I just
want to ok I want to cut Robin off let
me let Robin go ok kid afternoon ladies
and gentlemen first of all let me start
out by saying thank you for allowing me
the opportunity to share the world of
hiv/aids from a truly unique perspective
I chose the word you need for a very
specific reason my esteemed colleagues
can give you the cold hard facts figures
and statistics related to the current
pandemic called hiv/aids I on the other
hand and coming from a completely
different side of the spectrum I am a 48
year old african-american woman who
lives with hiv/aids every day of my life
i was diagnosed HIV positive back in
august of 2001 I do not tell you this
because I want your pity or your
sympathy I tell you this with the hope
that someone out there can learn from my
experience with this life-threatening
disease for the next 10 minutes I will
be your reality I am the face of
hiv/aids up close and personal
somewhere in the back of the minds of
one or two people if not more is that
all-too-familiar reaction she doesn't
look sick I would have never seen that
coming my point is hiv/aids is as
inclusive as it is elusive there is no
race gender or background connected to
hiv/aids the disease is universal now
that I've gotten that major revelation
out of the way let me tell you a little
bit about me and my experiences with
hiv/aids as I just told you a few
minutes ago I was diagnosed HIV positive
in 2001 and let me tell you that had to
be the single most devastating news I
have ever received to this day talk
about earth-shattering and mind-boggling
it was all that and more my first
reaction was compounded by the four most
difficult questions I've ever had to ask
myself questions that would take a
reasonably sane individual over the edge
toward mental breakdown the questions
were one why me too how could this
happen to me three what did I do wrong
and last but certainly not least how
soon am I going to die back then I had a
very difficult time answering those
questions because i did not know much
about hiv/aids and how one got this
disease i have since been well educated
and can answer all of the above for you
right now question 1 why me answer
because i naively thought that the
person i had been intimately involved
with for seven years and i were in a
monogamous relationship with one another
two years after we subsequently went our
separate ways I tested positive I
learned that was not the case at all
that was a hard and painful lesson in
retrospect had I known that when we were
together
that I could have and would have made a
logical decision to practice safe sex
instead of unprotected sex question shoe
how could this happen to me answer I
trusted that the person I was involved
with was only involved with me wrong I
later learn two years after my initial
diagnosis the other person he was
involved with died a full-blown AIDS
this speaks volumes to the point of how
it has become a fact that women overall
have the single highest transmission
rate of HIV AIDS today women of color in
particular are still believing the
fallacy that he is the one and I am his
one and only that belief alone can cost
you your life we need to practice safe
sex at all times no matter what he says
or what you choose to believe the simple
act of insisting on practicing safe sex
can greatly reduce the transmission of
hiv/aids and save many lives in the
process question 3 what did I do wrong
answer I was too many month I was too
much in love with the idea of being in
love with my partner to adequately
protect myself by simply insisting that
he put on a condom question for how soon
am I going to die answer I don't know
what I do know is that I've learned to
accept my fate and I'm determined to try
to make a difference in this world so
that others will not have to travel
along the same road that I am trapping
now that we've covered all the relevant
questions let's move on after my initial
shock wore off I was left to deal with
some very hard realities the first
medical professional I dealt with was
extremely indifferent toward any and all
of the emotional
dress that I was going through it felt
as though he didn't care what I was
going through he simply wanted to know
the names and addresses of any and
everyone I had ever had an intimate
relationship with after that he wanted
permission to run a second HIV test to
confirm beyond the shadow of a doubt my
initial diagnosis I signed the
permission slip he did the second test
and walked out the room with a fleeting
have a nice day talk about medical
inequity this was a nightmare two weeks
later my initial diagnosis was confirmed
and the same doctor who initially broke
the bad news wrote me a zillion
prescriptions and simply told me take
the pills end of discussion he never
told me about the side effects I would
encounter nor did he allow me time for
any questions I may have had and Lord
knows I had a lot of unanswered
questions our encounter was over and I
was left to deal with my newfound in
alone suffice it to say this was not at
all what I expected the doctor was the
man with all the answers and I was a
woman left in the dark needless to say I
left his office feeling quite despondent
to say the least ultimately I dealt with
my disease and the side effects of the
medications on my own I would not wish
this particular faith on anyone I
continued to see this doctor for two
years because I didn't know where else
to go for help after all he was the man
who went to medical school I assumed he
knew what he was doing one year after
that due to an unexpected drop in my
t-cells he calmly and quietly told me
that he was an internal medical doctor
and I needed to
find an infectious disease doctor wow it
took three years before it finally came
down to that this man had no clue what
happened to my t-cells how do we fix
this or at least get me back on the
right track I spent several weeks and
months calling HIV and aids service
organizations on my own trying to find
the doctor who would be able to help me
eventually I finally did find a female
african-american doctor who was able to
treat my disease and also treat me with
the dignity and respect I deserve she
did not judge me because of the disease
I have but she taught me how to live
with it she answered all my questions
and to this day is still my doctor my
friend and my confidence I've grown to
trust her decisions in regard to my care
and I never doubt her we are partners in
this fight to keep me alive and well she
will often tell me when something
doesn't feel right all you have to do is
pick up the phone I'm just a phone call
away and believe you me i do pick up the
phone and i make the call I've made that
call many times and she's always picked
up that phone as I stand before you
today I can honor you sleep I can
honestly say I have HIV but HIV does not
have me I'm going ahead and living my
life to the fullest and enjoying the
life that I live in conclusion it is my
hope that you have learned something
from my story in particular I would like
to say to all women of color we live in
a world that is no longer as clear as
black and white there is a lot of gray
matter in our relationships our society
and our world that gray matter can often
times be detrimental to our lives and
our very exist
if I could say one thing to you today I
would say please I beg you be careful be
safe and live well so that you will not
have to walk in my shoes thank you
you
the preceding program was brought to you
by Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes TC
columbia edu